[Music]
you know mankind is a symbolic species
which means that even physical pleasures
you know trivial things for other
animals mating habits eating
reproduction so on and so forth to us
becomes become cosmic acts you know
impregnated with significance we are
travelers in search of signification and
so even sensuality has been turned into
poetry you know Apes have sex human
beings make love you know and Alan
Harrington has great language says
sensuality may itself turn into a
feverish hunt for rebirth through Rapala
theosis were symbolic catharsis and I
just love this idea that you know us as
this meaning-making species the symbolic
representation of species all the
pleasure that we seem to get from the
world comes from the story we tell
ourselves about that experience like we
become the paintbrush you know we become
the meaning we are the answer to the
question we're asking I think that loop
is is fascinating
[Music]
you